hello and welcome to this vir conference
live presentation my name is sha Baker
and I'm the CSO of blue seek and today
what I'll be discussing is how NextGen
sequencing is driving the transition
from genetics to genomics so this is a
fairly complex uh topic and so I I'm
kind of expecting and hoping that you
have some questions for me and if you do
uh you can use the green Q&A button uh
if you click on that you can then type
in your questions and at the end of the
presentation I'll try to take some time
to answer as many of them as I
can so before we get started I think
it's important to say who blue seek is
and why you should be listening to us
and and what we have to say luek is an
online sequencing exchange we basically
match together researchers who want to
do sequencing with the providers who
have excess
capacity but we have actually um don't
offer any of the sequencing ourselves we
don't own any sequencers we don't do any
analysis we're just a neutral online
exchange so we match people together but
since we don't own any of the technology
we uh we feel we have an unusual uh
unique perspective on the market we pay
attention to what's happening today we
need to pay attention to what's
happening in the future but since we
don't own any of the technology we don't
have a stake in the game we can come at
it from a very neutral standpoint and
that's that neutral standpoint that
we're trying to share with you
today so before we get into um how nextg
sequencing is actually
transforming uh how Diagnostics is being
used and how genetics is changing into
gen genomics I want to take a step back
and talk about where this Market has
been where it is now and where we think
it's going in the future so first we'll
start out with who was driving this
Market I was really the Pioneers the
early adapters the Risk Takers so the
people who were intensely interested in
what the technology is exactly how it
works they like getting the technology
as soon as it's available they like
tearing it apart seeing how they can
make it better even sometimes seeing how
they could break it
down and they have a particular
mentality a certain uh characteristic
set and a certain
um types of things they're looking for
in a technology and looking for in a
market and primarily what they wanted
was uh dramatically increased output
that's what nextg sequencing was
offering so this graph here is just
giving um a relative overview it's not a
complete history it's just taking a look
at one particular company alumina and
their instruments over the past several
years they started out with a machine
called the selecta 1G and as the name
would imply it could output put about
one gigabase or one billion uh bases of
sequence but that rapidly changed once
alumina acquired them it got renamed the
ga or the genome analyzer and the output
was increased to five gigabases then
over the years it kept improving the new
model the ga2 to go up to 30 gigs that
then got improved to the 2x which was 50
gigs uh further improvements primarily
in terms of chemistry uh not so much the
hardware that actually got bumped up to
95 gigs the same time they also released
an even bigger instrument the highy 2000
which at launch could do 200 gigabases
of sequence per
run that was then uh in 2011 got its
latest upgrade which bumped up the
output to 600 gab bases and internal
runs were even bigger they they
announced that uh internally they could
get up to a terabase or so or a trillion
bases that's all in single run so in a
span of about four years we're looking
at nearly a thousandfold increase in the
output from these instruments and
obviously these early adopters just ate
that
up because you're getting these
increased outputs uh with more or less
the same cost per run the costs are
going to drop so if you look at 2001 the
cost per million basis sequenced was
around $5,000 or so and that was using a
pre nextg sequence or Sanger sequencing
Technologies and over the years that
slowly uh started dropping but you can
see that really precipitous drop there
in the middle that's when the nextg
sequencing Market really started heating
up a lot of competition just really
drove the prices down so in the
beginning of
2012 that same million bases that used
to cost
$5,000 then cost under 10 cents per
million bases so just a dramatic drop
across this time period of you know 11
years or so it's nearly a five order
magnitude drop so just tremendous
tremendously uh less expensive to run
the same kind of experiments and of
course when you drop things so radically
in terms of uh price it really opens up
things that you can do so projects that
weren't feasible before all of a sudden
people can start thinking about actually
doing them getting them done uh trying
new things they never never would have
even thought of trying before so it was
really empowering for these early
adopters to just uh completely rewrite
the way they were doing their
research so this of course resulted in
very expensive machines that produced a
whole lot of
data and produced that data over a
fairly long period of time generally in
the order of two two weeks to a month
even um so this was really good for big
projects uh researchers who had a lot of
data that they wanted to
generate and the market players here
year uh you know 454 was the initial
nextg sequencing player alumina and came
on the market a little bit later
followed very shortly by Life
Technologies with their solid machines
but at this point for the high-end uh
massive amount of M massive amounts of
data per run it was really alumina that
came out as the deao leader the other
players are still in the market you can
still get 454 you see research being
done over them um the solid as well is
still out there but they aren't nearly
as active as the aluminate platform so
at least in this segment of the market
um the race is more or less over until a
new competitor comes on on the
scene so that that was then that was
sort of who kicked off this next gen
sequencing market in terms of the buyers
but the question is now that those early
adopters have uh have adopted the
technology have started publishing
papers What's Happening Now what what's
happening now then is is more of the
mass maret Market the everyday
researcher uh the people who certainly
are interested in sequencing they want
to use it but they're not really they
wouldn't consider themselves sequencing
people they are more interested in their
own research they just want to take what
they've been doing use the new
technologies to make it better make it
faster make it cheaper and as I said
because this incredible increase in
capability and decrease in price it's
opened up all new possibilities of of of
what's available on the research side so
these people can then expand what they
were doing but again they're focusing
more on their research getting their
work done simply using these nextg
sequencers as tools rather than really
trying to dig into the details of the
sequencer and what it does so these
people have different needs than the
early
adopter so these initial instruments are
extremely expensive so anywhere from
half a million dollars up to
$800,000 and then you even have
additional cost for other ancillary
instruments data storage things like
that so extremely expensive that's fine
for someone who's really dedicating
their research to using these machines
247 but for the the more typical
researcher who wants to just Advance his
own program that's too much and so the
market has responded with much uh
smaller instruments these are desktop
instruments rather than um things that
can be so heavy they actually require
reinforced flooring and they're also
much cheaper so $50,000 at the low end
to 125,000 or up to maybe even 200 but
the point is substantially less
expensive than what the market was
serving
before the other thing that the this uh
segment of the market wanted were
quicker runtime so you know rather than
uh having an experiment take two weeks
three weeks maybe even four weeks they
want it to be done in hours uh and or at
least in within a day or two
and that's what these new instruments
are
providing the other thing of course is
looking for a lower cost per run at the
highend these machines uh a single run
can cost as much as $20,000 or more just
in just in reagents and now with a new
machines they can be as little as a few
hundred dollars so this is uh makes it
much more conducive to doing quick rapid
lowcost experiments doing a little
playing around seeing what you get going
back looking at the data
and then uh revising and running another
experiment when you have a big long two
we three we experiment that costs
$20,000 you have to be much more careful
of the planning much more certain of
what you're putting in and what you're
trying to get
out the other thing that um really
everyone's been looking for not just
this uh the mass Market but also the
early adopters everyone wanted increase
read links so when the alumina system
came out it was is producing really just
25 bases per uh per read so read Links
of just 25 bases and this would be in
contrast to around a thousand bases or
so at least at least several hundred
bases for the initial Sanger sequencing
technology that it was trying to
displace so uh 25 basis obviously isn't
nearly as long isn't nearly as useful
but because there were so many of the
reads um it it's still uh people were
still able to get a lot of good use out
of it but in order to increas that
utility they really wanted to expand on
this and get these longer and longer
reads so what started out at 25 bases uh
was relatively shortly doubled to 50
lately we've seen 100 base reads uh and
200 base reads become common and we even
have had 400 base reads released on
certain
Technologies uh on some specialty
instrument from Pacific biosciences or
PAC bio they even have average reads
that are about 5,000 days as long with
the smaller number of those reads
reaching into the 20 KB uh range so
clearly uh once you start getting these
these longer bases longer
reads again it really starts opening up
various applications that become
possible and so people are pretty
excited about this and there's been a
lot of progress made but we would expect
uh even more effort to be placed here in
the
future so the the primary Market players
for this uh Mass Market segment are the
the ones we've talked about before Life
Technologies with their PGM and proton
machines and then alumina with their my
seek machine um there are a couple other
smaller players but these are really the
the two key ones and unlike on the high
end where alumina really has won that
race and dominated the market um this
race is by no means dominated by either
one it's it's a highly competitive
situation uh both these machines are
actively being improved um so uh it's
actually a really good thing for the for
the buyers out there because these
companies can't rest on their Laurels
they really need to keep improving to
make sure that uh they remain
competitive so the unfortunate thing
though with what's been focused on over
the past couple years is that it really
hasn't had much of an impact on SE
sequencing costs so while during the
first 11 years or so this graph we
showed a nearly five order magnitude
drop in in cost from 2012 the beginning
of 2012 to about now so about a year and
a half the pricing has really been quite
flat it even occasionally ticks up
whenever one of the vendors uh increases
their pricing but uh we haven't been
seeing that rapid drop in price that has
almost been the definition of what next
gen sequencing is so some people are
starting to get a little bit concerned
about this um it's probably not that big
of a deal it's really just a matter of
these companies responding to what the
market really wants and so what this
means is that the cost right now isn't
the primary concern but at some point of
course it's going to become that concern
I expect to have uh increased
competition in the future that will
probably also help the drive this cost
down but for now um you know you really
shouldn't be relying on those
precipitous drops that we've been seeing
over the past few years at the moment
it's fairly flat
pricing so we've talked about sort of
who started this Market uh and and who's
dominating now in ter terms of buying
these machines and what they're using
them for but very soon question becomes
well who's going to be driving the
market in the future and the future is
more or less right now and that's
Physicians and
clinicians so unlike the early adopters
they have absolutely no interest in the
details of how the sequencing is working
they just want to see the results even
more so than um what I would call the
mass research Market they really just
care about those end results how the
sequencing data is going to impact how
they help their patients uh guiding
their diagnosis and that that's what
they're focused on so that the qualities
that they're interested in they really
want higher quality data uh everyone
wants high quality data but it's it's
hand amount for the phys in clins and we
can see from this graph this is just
showing a a typical quality curve so on
the um on the left hand side we actually
see the quality scores and then along
the bottom we're plotting the the length
of the read and as the reads get longer
and longer the quality starts dropping
off and that's actually what the
ultimate read limit is on most of the
Technologies they could read longer but
the data becomes so poor quality that it
just doesn't really add anything to the
experiment kind of cut it off um and
that mostly works fine for uh the
research Market but for the clinical
Market where they're really trying to
look at potentially uh rare phenotypes
or or rare Snips they want to have a
really low false positive and false
negative rate the high quality is
extremely important to them and that's
what the market will likely be focusing
on delivering over the next two
years another thing is
uh I'd say better and easier data
analysis and interpretation so what
we're looking at here is a very typical
routine file called the Fass Q this
shows um the actual sequence data along
with some information about each read
including the quality so this particular
snippet that I'm showing you is looking
at just three reads from a run but these
runs can be is is uh anywhere from a few
million reads up to three billion or so
reads so this is is a a huge amount of
data in this particular format while
incredibly useful for someone who um can
handle large data files isn't very
useful for an individual to start poking
around and seeing what's going on with a
patient a more useful file would be the
VCF um and this is basically a file
that's looking at the variance so rather
than recoring all the raw sequence we're
just looking at what variants are there
and specifically we're saying what
changes are present in this particular
sample as compared to some common
reference sample and these are the the
places within the genome that the
physician might want to look into
especially if it falls in line with a
particular Gene that might be related to
phenotype that patient has so this is
getting more useful but as you can see
it's still difficult to actually glean
anything by just looking at this raw
file they need better and better tools
to get them where they really need to go
that is making the diagnosis so data
visualization tools are getting better
too and they'll continue to demand even
better ones and as we can see this
starts becoming a little more um easy to
interpret what's going on at the top end
there we have uh an image of one
chromosome and in the middle what we're
looking at here is actually RNA seek
data and on the bottom is a zoomed in
view of one particular Gene that we're
looking at and because it's RNA data we
can see that all reads are actually
aligning to the coding regions of the
exons and very few reads in the
intervening are intronic regions the
point is that uh this gives a much
easier way of looking at what's going on
it's easy to see that these genes are
here I can see where the reads are but
we're only looking at one gene at a time
and uh while that can be useful if you
know that you're interested in that
particular Gene if you're trying to look
at what's going on at all 20,000 this
isn't particularly useful or at least
not useful enough
so where I think we're going to see the
most Improvement are the actual medical
reports that come out at the very end so
here we're not interested at all what
all that raw data looks like even what
all the um variants look like if you
take a a typical individual and compare
them sequence them and then compare that
data to the common reference sample
you're still going to get you know
several million variants several million
differences between them and obviously
most of those aren't going to have any
medical relevance whatsoever but a small
number will and those are the ones that
phys Physicians want to see they want to
see that data in uh a very easy readable
format they want to see it in a way that
lets them take that information and
immediately apply it directly to their
patient to say okay I know they have
this particular phenotype I see some
lesions in uh these genes or these
Pathways which are related to that
phenotype this gives me a clue as as to
uh what the next steps are help help me
make that diagnosis and so we're just
starting to see that a little bit later
in the presentation I'll actually show
you um some of the companies are
actually at the Forefront of this making
uh this information better in terms of
what's presented and also in terms of
How It's
presented okay so the market players
that we would expect to see to serve
this Market The Physician Market is is
probably going to be the same uh Life
Technologies and are certainly both
working very hard to um try to make
their products uh better for this
particular Market but we're also likely
to see many many others come along I
mean as you move away from the research
market and move into the medical or
clinical Market it just gets so much
bigger and that uh starts just
attracting many new players offering uh
services that just aren't offered by the
current players there's a lot of future
technology IES uh that are out there
people are working on that might be the
next things that maybe either displace
life or Lumina or even potentially get
acquired by life for
Lumina uh one segment of that has been
the nanopore companies there's been a
lot of news and a lot of excitement
about these companies they still haven't
actually delivered on this yet so this
is still a little bit more experimental
but the idea is to take uh a nanop just
BAS have small pore either based on a
protein like alpha
hin or uh sometimes people make solid
state ones but the idea is that as the
DNA molecule is drawn through that
nanopore it creates a change in the
current and that change can be
Associated at least that's the the
hypothesis that that change in current
can be associated with individual bases
so if you could um get this to work you
could have a very cheap very fast and
potentially high quality sequence being
generated um and because of this this
great potential there's a lot of
companies working on this and I'm just
showing you some of the main ones here
but there's other strategies um there
are a number of companies who aren't
using nanopores but instead looking at
uh electronic detection so as each base
is incorporated or as each base is um
queried it can have a different
electrical signal and there's a number
of companies working on better ways of
of measuring those signals and turning
into high quality
data there are even companies that are
looking at uh basically transmission
electron micrograph or tem based
Technologies where they're literally
looking at each base individually trying
to make a call the advantage of these is
if they do it well they could actually
get extremely long reads so I talked
about typical nextg sequencing reads
being in the 150 up to 400 base range
with a specialty instrument from pack
bio you can get pretty big at 5 KB or so
but but these instruments they're
talking about starting at 50 KB to 100
KB so really really long distance reads
and that starts opening up new
possibilities in terms of uh what
applications are available getting
longrange information looking at
rearrangements things that right now are
possible with other next end
Technologies but much more difficult to
do and then there's a whole slew of
other technologies that are out there
that are filling in little niches but
the point is that if you can see from
the slide which isn't even complete
there are a lot of people right out on
the horizon looking to make that next
next gen sequencing
system so we kind of talked about the
technology and and how it's evolved and
who it's been serving and now the
question becomes um how is this
technology actually being used in the
clinic
um so before we do that I kind of want
to lay out this graph that I'm going to
show this this image that I'm going to
show repeatedly and that's getting at
the idea of what genetics versus
genomics is so on the left hand side we
just have uh sort of a representation of
all the
chromosomes on the upper right we're
zooming in and we're looking at just one
Gene and in that Gene we have the coding
regions or the exons which are in blue
and then the green regions uh which are
the introns or non-coding regions
and then zooming in further on the lower
right we're actually looking at the
individual bases so just so you know
that that that's what this graph is
showing we we'll show it multiple times
here so kind of the quintessential
genetic test is typically based on PCR
cimmer chain reaction and in these tests
they look at a single Locus so that's
what that red line is meant to represent
on that one particular chromosome we
zoom in and look at the gene again we're
Landing in one particular Exxon and then
zooming in once again we're seeing that
the PCR uh diagnostic or test is looking
at a particular base so just one base
out of the entire genome now PCR can be
Multiplex so you could actually get a
few of these going together that each
individual test is actually only looking
either at one base or potentially the
presence or absence of of a longer
sequence but the amount of data that's
that's returned is pretty minimal and as
you can see in the lower uh Side Lower
um part of the slide there uh one Locus
with extremely low coverage as would be
expected uh PCR really is primarily used
in the diagnostic space for pathog
pathogen detection like for HIV or
hepatitis um it can be used to determine
whether the virus is present uh and also
if it is present it can be used to
determine viral load which can be
important for certain diseases but it's
also it can be used used for more
traditional what we can traditional
human genetic testing so one example of
that is the egfr testing um in this
particular case PCR is used to determine
what particular Al of egfr is present
and each AO will actually have a
different
prognosis uh for non-s small cell lung
cancers so again uh this is sort of a a
classic genetic test we've got lung
cancer it's important to know you know
which version of that Gene do I have
have and depending on what you have
that's going to obviously change your
prognosis but also probably help guide
your position as to what treatments you
should be receiving how aggressive they
should
be the other uh major genetic test would
be the classic Sanger sequencing so
again we're looking at uh one one
particular Gene as it's noted there on
the left hand side looking at one red
line going through the chromosome but in
this case rather than looking at a
single base we're actually looking at
what's probably the entire gene or at
least a very large trunk of it generally
Sanger is able to produce about a
thousand bases uh per run so um that
generally won't cover an entire Gene but
a fairly large region of a gene at least
and the other important thing is that
all those thousand bases are completely
contiguous so they're all right next to
each other we're getting not data from
just one spot within the gene but all
the information about that Gene that we
can um there are there are actually lots
and lots of examples of clinical test
used with Sanger sequencing it's really
right now considered the gold standard
for sequencing based diagnostic that's
primarily because of its low error rate
um the ABI genetic analyser analyzer
from Life Technologies is really the
dominant player here there there're
probably one or two other uh minor
platforms but this is the one people
have been using and is generally
considered the gold
standard
so the first two technologies I talked
about were very clearly genetic tests
now we're moving to the range where it's
pushing into genomic some people might
not consider this genomic test but but
in general it would be this is a focused
array and on the focused array rather
than looking at one particular Locus or
one particular Gene we're actually
talking about at say maybe a thousand or
so different Loi throughout the entire
genome uh and so you can see that as
it's designated on the left that means
that we might look at one or even maybe
a handful of bases within a particular
Gene but again the coverage is going to
be very very low around a thousand bases
out of the six billion or
so um these focused rays are being used
in the clinic so we have the cytochrome
for 50 array uh from Ro using apy
technology this is for looking at uh
drug response and dose response um
helping uh helping to determine uh you
know what the dosing is should be for
particular drugs or whether certain
drugs should be used or avoided the
other one uh the other example that I've
pulled up here is the mammo print and
that's from agendia and this is looking
at the breast cancer prognosis and again
in both cases we're talking about
looking at a number of locations
throughout the genome but still using
that single based multilex technology of
the focused
array getting into uh what's much more
comfortably called genomic technology or
genomic diagnostic will be whole genome
arrays so again like the focused array
we're looking at um locations throughout
the genome but we're looking at a lot
more instead of a thousand we're talking
about looking at at a million or even to
five million and so with that many
markers of course they're going to be
spread out across the genome you're
going to get multiple markers per Gene
and so we see we're we're looking at uh
markers within the coding regions um
also in introns not shown here but you'd
also be looking at intergenic regions
the Gen regions that aren't connected
with any particular
Gene but again the coverage is still
pretty low so the chances of having an
immediate neighbor are are quite low um
mostly you're just looking at one base
per Locus and then you might just have
multiple bases per
Gene so the dominant platforms here
again these are array based that
primarily be from alumina and NY metrics
there are a couple others but those are
the the primary players and the main use
uh for these arrays is really genomewide
Association studies or GSE the idea here
is uh looking at those million or five
million or so Snips or single nucle typ
polymorphisms differences between people
and trying to associate them with a
particular phenotype say susceptibility
to diabetes 2 or something type two
diabetes um uh this has been used quite
a lot there's over 1350 published
studies so far um but these really
primarily isn't directly used for
diagnosis this is primarily used as a
research tool to discover the
information that would be used to uh
generate a diagnostic tool using a
different techn techology but gws has
been extremely popular for a long time
this graph which I realiz is probably a
little hard to read is just showing um
the categories of all the different
types of gws hits that have been found
and how they're displayed or or how they
um distributed rather across the entire
genome so lots and lots of
information getting back to the
sequencing
technology um and specifically with next
gen sequencing we have something called
targeted sequencing so here uh similar
to the whole genome arrays we're looking
at about a million bases or so roughly
but in this case rather than looking at
one million discret bases we're looking
at contiguous pieces a very typical
thing to do would be to focus on uh
mostly the coding regions but uh as as
these targeted sequencing products are
usually customized
you can really Target it to any
particular region of interest you could
have these targeted regions spread out
across the entire genome or you could
have them focused on a certain set of
genes that are involved in a particular
pathway but regardless of of how they're
targeted you're going to see that the uh
calls are are grouped together in these
continuous
bases there are a number of ways that
this targeted sequencing is being used
in the the clinic um generally for
multi- Gene tests so the idea of rather
than testing for one gene at a time one
condition at a time to pull all this
together into a single test that can
test for many things and that's really
the power of moving from genetic testing
genomic testing so in this particular
example I'm showing you here this is
from Foundation Health they have a test
called Foundation one where they're
looking at uh basically sequencing
approximately 250 cancer related genes
so if you if you have cancer or if you
have a patient with cancer you can use
this one test to sequence all the genes
that are most likely to be involved in
that cancer either directly in causing
it or genes that are affected by cancer
and so rather than trying to determine
which particular Gene that you might
want to focus on you can order this one
test and get all the results across all
the cancer related genes right there
together another example uh another
company is in v and they're doing a
similar kind of thing but rather than
focusing on cancer they're actually
trying to convert all the single Gene
genetic tests that are available today
into a single multi- Gene sequencing
based test so what they have right now
is they have a test that covers um I
think it's a little more than 200 genes
covering about
260 uh genetic
conditions and what you can do is you
can look at their catalog of all these
conditions that they cover and you can
order one or two or a handful or you can
order all
262 but the price is actually the same
and right now that price is around
$1,500 and the way it works is no matter
what you order out of that catalog
they're going to run the same test
they're going to sequence across all
those 200 genes covering all 262
conditions and then just report back on
whichever ones that you actually were
interested in and so it's it's up to the
the user The Physician to decide whether
they want to look at just a handful that
are associated with what their patient
uh needs or whether they just want to
run the whole test and inv has plans to
increase this um like I said right now
it's about 262 conditions for
$1,500 by 2014 they hope to have over a
thousand conditions and have the test
cost under a thousand so they're really
trying to push hard on on moving away
from Individual genetic test to a single
comprehensive genomic test and then
using informatics to help you decide
whether or not you actually want to look
at all those or just a subset of
them so sort of moving up the scale in
terms of complexity we have exom
sequencing which really is is a form of
targeted sequencing it's just the most
extreme form that we have so far and
that's what we're targeting every single
coding region of the genome so here
we're talking about 40 megabases and as
we've seen before with the other
sequencing Technologies all these bases
that are being sequenced or continuous
uh we're starting to get pretty
significant coverage so we're talking a
little over 1% coverage of the genome
still not full coverage by any means but
substantially more than any of the
technologies that we've looked at so
far uh one step up from that of course
would be the Holy Grail of a genomic
test and that's whole genum sequencing
and here just drawn a big rght box over
all the chromosomes because we're
targeting everything um all the cating
regions all the andronic regions all the
energenic regions all the individual
bases now as a practical matter um the
technologies that are available today
can't really hit 100% of the sequence
they typically hit about 90% And they
cover that 90% pretty well the other
missing 10% is basically just harder
it's regions like the tiers and the
centr meters or other regions that have
um a lot of repeat sequence that just
difficult to sequence through and people
are making improvements all the time
trying to up that 90% even higher and
higher but in general that's what a
nextg sequencing test would
cover the question then is is this
massive technology it's very expensive
it's still fairly timec consuming it
certainly produces a lot of data um is
it able to be used in the clinic the
answer is yes it is already being used
in the clinic so the primary example uh
that people are using this for is cancer
patients so cancer studies of use
sequencing for a long time but this is
the idea of actually looking at the
cancer cells of an individual patient
comparing cancer cells with normal cells
and trying to use that information to to
determine exactly what type of cancer it
is so it's kind of an old Paradigm to
say that people will have either liver
cancer or breast cancer or lung cancer
um but that is not really the best way
to look at it what's really important is
the molecular origin the molecular
nature of that cancer what is the actual
genomic lesion that's going on and so
this is an expensive procedure so it's
not usually the first line of defense
it's uh often used on patients who have
stopped responding to other treatments
who have maybe extremely rare form
cancer where there are no known
treatments but there are a number of
cases uh where individuals have been
sequenced and have their um diagnostic
treatment uh
change um and and actually have new
drugs and new treatments that applied to
them that wouldn't have otherwise been
even attempted because it wasn't known
there was any evidence that it might
work but when you do this whole genome
sequencing in cancer you're actually
getting a lot more information
and it's really helping um The
Physicians uh push on and try to decide
what to do with their patient now this
isn't a Panacea it's not easy it's still
a lot of data it it almost really should
be considered more of an individual
research project uh it takes a lot of
effort from a lot of people to really
crunch through all that data quickly
enough to help that patient but people
are starting to work on this and they're
starting to learn more and try to to
make this analysis happen faster so that
it can become more
routine another uh similar kind of use
would be for rare childhood diseases and
again these are cases where either there
aren't any known treatments or
treatments that have been tried aren't
working and so again almost as an
individual research project they will
sequence the entire Genome of that child
and maybe even the genomes of the
parents do a trio analysis to really see
what novel genomic lesions are present
in that child that could help uh
determine exactly what's causing the
phenotype and again it runs the whole
gam of responses there's been some where
even after genomic sequencing nothing
has been determined so it's unclear uh
all the way through uh being able to
determine that relatively simple
treatments can be applied and in some
cases it's made just tremendous dramatic
improvements in the lives of these
children so again it's still very
expensive it's still um uh very complex
and takes a lot of work but it it has
been showing such dramatic results and
in this case there's even um we're even
seeing um reimbursement from from the
insurance companies uh because treating
a a child with these diseases and going
through all the testing and on all the
treatments can be extremely expensive so
even if the sequencing is $10,000 and
say 20 $30,000 for the analysis that can
be much cheaper than other treatments or
other testings which can be in the multi
100,000 range so expensive as it is it
still can be considered um feasible to
do the other area uh which has seen an
explosion recently is the nip or
non-invasive prenatal testing so in this
case um rather than doing an MOS
sythesis which is a fairly invasive
procedure to directly look at the DNA
from the cells of the fetus in these
tests they actually take blood from the
mother and there turns out there's
enough fetal DNA floating around in the
maternal blood and there's enough um
depth of sequencing available with these
next gen sequencing technology and
there's enough sophisticated analysis
they can actually tease all that apart
and so as you can imagine going from a
an invasive procedure to another non
invasive procedures was very attractive
so there's a number of companies that
have been formed around this idea of
doing nip testing and it's been uh
fairly successful and is gaining um
gaining a lot of converts lately so this
is definitely an area of intense focus
in in the cross between nextg sequencing
and the diagnostic
space I see we have a couple questions
coming in I'll just remind everyone as
they're uh listening to me if you have
any questions please type them into that
Q&A panel and I will uh try to answer
them when we're all
done
so given given what we've seen and and
this push towards uh genomic testing and
and uh maybe not away from genetic
testing but certainly is a is a
complement to genetic testing there are
um there going to be some difficulties
going forward and one of those
difficulties is certainly going to be
analyzing the data so this is just an
overview of the types of data analysis
that are that are uh involved in next
gen SE data we have primary analysis um
which is base calling and QC of the data
secondary is assembling that data and
aligning it tertiary is a group that
would be calling the variants annotating
the variants visualizing the data and
also maybe looking at some physical
analysis of the data and then finally we
have reporting that's Tak all that data
and crunching it down to a single
hopefully easyto read report that can
summarize everything that's been done
and laying over on top of all of that
would just be uh the idea of data
management you know storing that data
moving data around understanding where
it is and databasing
it so um the primary data analysis is
really then the purview of the vendors
uh and they've done a good job of this
and mostly people just kind of trust
them with it and and move on to the next
one which is uh secondary secondary
analysis or the the assembly and
alignment of DNA sequences that was what
the uh early adopters really focused on
a lot they spent a lot of energy there's
a lot of tools out there to do different
uh you know different algorithms for
assembly and alignment and um uh trying
to get a little bit faster a little bit
better uh when you're talking about the
mass Market they still cared about that
secondary analysis but they also started
caring more about the tertiary analysis
once you've aligned the data I want to
look at it I want to see what variants
are there I want to look at the
annotations of those variants and I want
to visualize it but when we talk of
going to the the third major segment the
future segment of the clinicians and
Physicians they're really going to care
about the tertiary and then even more so
about the recordings they're still going
to carry about those annotations and
make sure the annotations are good but
what they want is that final report they
want to hold it in their hand they don't
want to look at the terabase or terabyte
of data that comes out of each
sequencing project but they want to just
look at that report and say Here's my
patient here's what they have here's
what their genome looks like and here's
the information I need to help start
making a diagnosis and that's going to
be a major push going forward there are
a number of new companies that have been
formed that are really working very hard
both at making better annotations but
also making better presentations and
better reports so that the Physicians
can get to that information as quickly
as
possible so the question then becomes
what's the impact on patients we talked
about technology and and who using it
but who is it going to be used on and
there's a really big question right now
about what exactly should the patients
be allowed to see um should they have
access to their entire genomic data or
for they only see the small bits that
the physician has determined are
relevant to the question at hand and
this is almost a religious debate you
see people arguing very strongly on both
sides of this um so it's by no means
been resolved but it is an active area
of
discussion of particular concern is this
idea of the incidental Lo uh this would
be the collected unexpected findings in
a genomic test so if you're doing a
genetic test this doesn't become an
issue with you if you're doing a a
simple test to determine how you're
going to respond to a particular drug
you do that one particular test you get
that result it's probably going to be a
yes or no that's all you find out and
you make a decision with your pH
accordingly you take a particular drug
or you change the dosage of that drug
but when you start doing a genomic test
you can find out not just that one
particular thing you're looking for the
handful of things you're looking for you
can find out everything and you might
find some things that
either are just unknown you might have
some variants you actually will have
variants you'll have several million
variants uh many of them will have
nothing associated with them clinically
they won't know anything about them some
might be unknown but in genes of known
significance and that might be
disconcerting you also might find some
variants that are of
known that have known issues for example
if you're go for a simple dosage test
and you find out you have uh the defect
in the Huntington's dis disease Gene uh
that can be very unsettling so it's it's
unclear exactly what the best process is
right now like I said some people are
arguing for full disclosure for everyone
all the time in other you're arguing for
a very uh protracted view of of the
information so the acmg has uh tried if
not to settle this argument at least to
uh bring some order to to the discussion
and so they've kind of drawn A A Line in
the Sand and made a set of
recommendations where they're saying
that there are 56 genes for which any
abnormal results should be reported to
the patient regardless of the patient's
wishes so even without determining ahead
of time from the patient whether they
did or did not want to know these
results they're saying that these
results should always be reported
because they're significant enough and
they're actionable something can be done
with this information so not everyone
agrees with this but it is nice to see
this group come out with a set of
recommendations and it certainly served
as a point of discussion going
forward the other thing to ask of course
is exactly how this genomic technology
is going to impact single Gene
intellectual property so I'm sure most
of you have probably been aware of the
uh Supreme Court case looking at myriads
claims for uh rockco one and two testing
for breast cancer um the results were
interesting there were three particular
claims that were looked at and basically
what came about was the unanimous
decision that for naturally occurring
Gene sequences those could not be
patented and um uh they weren't
protected so other companies or other
individuals could use that
information um this was generally seen
as a as a big success uh big win for
patients and almost immediately a number
of companies came out and either stated
that they were immediately offering uh
braa one and two testing for Ambry
genetics and Gene by Gene or two of
those and then a handful of other
companies said that they were um you
know in the process of of doing so and
so this again was considered a
tremendous success a tremendous uh win
for for
patients which is exactly what people
wanted but then almost as immediately
mad came back and said well no that's
not right we lost that one particular
case but we have all sorts of other
claims that weren't determined on so we
think we still have the right to so it's
uh certainly not a clear picture but
it's definitely difficult to imagine how
single Gene intellectual property is
going to hold up in the face of genomic
technology so it's one thing when you're
purposely trying to sequence a
particular Gene and that Gene is
protected but it's equally difficult to
understand how you could somehow have to
block that Gene information when you're
in sequence when you're sequencing your
entire genome so I'm sure we're going to
see a lot more about this uh in the near
future so the other thing I want to just
leave you with is um what we've been
talking about today is the genomic
Technologies looking at NextGen
sequencing for looking at the DNA but it
turns out of course our bodies are much
more complex than that we have the
methylome to look at so methylation and
other regulatory sequences and
structures to look at we also have the
transcriptome looking at uh coding genes
looking at non-coding genes and we even
have the um metagenome so the collective
genomes of all the microorganisms that
are in your body and these of course all
of these are going to have medical
impacts and will be are being looked at
in the research uh realm but will
certainly be used in the diagnostic
realm going forward so just we just at
the beginning of this just at the very
uh tip of the iceberg if you
will so finally uh I I'll leave you with
that uh I just want to say that this of
course is a very uh complex field fast
moving lots of things happening all the
time so I would strongly encourage you
to uh look at our website blue seek.com
we have a neutral repository of
information uh I will be answering
questions here shortly but if for some
reason I don't get you a question or you
think of one later please feel free to
reach out to me I'm at sbaker seek.com
and finally for those who are interested
in contain um obtaining continuing
education credits there's a website uh
that you can go to to take the test to
uh achieve those
credits okay with that um let's go ahead
and
see what kind of questions we have
um
[Music]
so uh some people are asking about um
whether they'll they can um see this
presentation later my understanding is
that all these presentations are uh are
going to be available as a recording for
a full year after after today so you can
certainly log back in and look at those
um I'm also more than willing to share
these slides with anyone who wants them
so if you actually want those slides uh
pre please just send me a email to
sbaker BL seek.com and I'd be uh happy
to send them to you
um another question is talking
about the um idea of going from the
sequencing cost of to day of of roughly
$10,000 to ,000 and is that going to be
a reality um I certainly think it will
be so uh you know this thousand genome
has been uh sort of something hanging
there kind of the uh the prize that uh
people have been trying to reach for a
for a long time and uh it's it's almost
reached a mythical or magical proportion
but the truth is that $1,000 isn't
really any more significant than the
$4,000 that really a research genome
cost today so of course it's a little
bit less money but the point is the
prices have come down so much that uh it
really has transformed what people are
doing in the biological sciences so it's
it's already been quite amazing of
course as it goes lower that will just
open up even new applications for people
to look at um personally I don't I think
it will hit the Thousand genome and but
I don't think it will stop there there
are certainly some of these far-reaching
Technologies which at least have the
promise of um going even lower to say
maybe even a $100 per genome so the
lower it goes it's really just going to
um increase all the
possibilities um okay so I think I've
mostly got the questions answered there
but again if you have any uh other
questions you think of later please
don't hesitate to contact me uh with
that thank you very much for your time
and I enjoy presenting to
you